Hey there, I'm Jack Cable and today I'm
going to be talking about the effects of
the AI bug apocalypse. As you may have
seen, frontier models are getting better
than ever before at discovering and
exploiting vulnerabilities in our
software. Right, this is leading to what
many are calling a bug apocalypse where
we're finding more and more
vulnerabilities, particularly in the
open-source libraries that power um all
of the software we rely upon. Right, so
today I want to break down what exactly
is happening and how defenders can get
ahead of the exploitation that is
occurring.
As far as my background, right now I'm
the co-founder and CEO at Corridor, a
company I started about 18 months ago
focused on securing AI coding.
Before this, I served as a senior
technical advisor in government at CISA,
the Cybersecurity and Infrastructure
Security Agency, where I worked with top
software companies to help them build
their products to be more secure by
design. I'm also an ethical hacker. I
got into the top 100 rank of hackers on
when I was in high school. I studied
computer science at Stanford. So I've
seen firsthand how these simple, you
know, repeat classes of vulnerabilities
can be introduced and exploited and have
been um close participant right in many
of the the most recent um advancements
and seeing just what this means uh for
both our adversaries as well as
defenders.
Just to set the stage, right, as
everyone here knows, I imagine AI coding
tools are scaling faster than any
software category in history. Cursor,
Copilot Code um grow exponentially and
with that, right, also comes these
improvements in how frontier models can
find and exploit vulnerabilities. Um so
we're seeing, right, both ends of the
equation shifting. On one hand, um
models can do better job finding
vulnerabilities. On the other hand, our
attack surfaces are growing immensely,
right, as AI becomes the default code
writer.
Um so, what I want to explore in this
talk, right, is how do we balance that?
How do we make sure that we're not going
to have immensely more vulnerabilities
than we've ever had before, right? And
just to to give some sense, right, I'll
move myself here of um some of the
statistics, right, um pulled some from
last year where about 84% of developers
were using AI coding tools, 30 to 40% of
companies encouraging use of AI coding
assistants. That was from Stack
Overflow, right? I don't I haven't seen
the latest numbers this year, but what I
would expect once those come out, right,
is that is the vast, vast majority of
developers and companies who are using
coding agents, right? And part of this
is the increasing level of autonomy by
which these coding agents are being
used. It's no longer, you know, auto
complete, often it's not even a
developer synchronously within cursor.
Um right, when we do our own
development, right, now it's
um spinning up agents from within Slack
or wherever folks are working
and having many agents run at once in
the background. Um this is a tremendous
shift in how software is being built, um
and at the same time, right, like I
mentioned, the frontier models are
getting significantly better.
Um and you can look at it from, you
know, pretty much any part of the cyber
attack chain, ranging from finding
vulnerabilities where models can, you
know, now do do,
you know, significantly better than even
I could, and you know, I've I've
reported hundreds of vulnerabilities to
various companies.
Um so, everything from finding
vulnerabilities to exploiting them. Uh
this is a chart here that comes from
Anthropic, right, showing Mythos
compared to a number of um other models
that they and others have put out. Um
and we can see that we're we're seeing
quite rapid advancements in models'
capabilities, right, And and
particularly to execute
more kind of autonomous attack chains.
So, as we think about adversaries who
are using these models, right? They're
not just going to be discovering
vulnerabilities, but they're going
to be automating every part of the
attack process. So, it's our job, right?
As defenders to understand, okay, what
are the points where we can make
software systems more resilient to all
of these attacks. Right? And to me, this
brings back a lot of the work that I was
doing in government around the the
secure by design initiative, right?
Um and so so the overall question,
right? That I'm worried about is how can
we make sure that frontier AI models
aren't introducing exponentially more
vulnerabilities over time, right? Um
even pre-AI, we've had this
you know, uh heavy increase in common,
relatively simple classes of
vulnerabilities that are being exploited
by adversaries. AI is making this
significantly easier, right? So, I think
the only way that we're going to to win
as defenders is if we use the the same
techniques, right? To harden our
systems. Um and I would say that there
is good news here, right? That a lot of
the vulnerabilities, pretty much all of
the vulnerabilities that even frontier
AI models are finding aren't anything
new. Yes, it's new that uh given
vulnerability was found in a you know,
specific file with with a piece of
software, but that vulnerability class
um isn't necessarily novel. Um and and
we can actually use that to our
advantage, and I'll I'll get into that.
Um right? So so overall, um the the
thesis here is that um right? We are
seeing both attackers get more tools in
their toolkit, and the same time, the
way in which software is being built is
fundamentally changing. Um so so really
the question then becomes how can we
apply AI to shore up on software
systems?
Um right, and I want to to take a
quick detour um to some of the secure by
design work that that I I kicked off
with with others in government. Um
right, this is a paper that we put out
in March of 2023. So, just as you know,
LLMs were starting to become more
readily available, but um right, their
application in coding at that time
wasn't much more than, you know, auto
complete. And while that's useful, it
wasn't necessarily the step change that
we have now. Um and what we focused on
kind of laying out with this vision,
right, was this idea that
it it isn't really rocket science when
it comes to preventing vulnerabilities
in software, right? While it's true that
it's hard to build a perfectly secure
system, we do know how to build systems
that are fundamentally more resilient to
common classes of vulnerabilities. Um
and and just to, you know, make this
concrete, um this is a set of
vulnerability classes coming from MITRE.
It's the
uh top classes that are um exploited in
CISA's known exploited vulnerabilities
catalog, right? And if you go down this
list, you'll you might notice, right,
that pretty much all of these are basic
types of vulnerabilities that not only
have we known about for decades, but
we've known how to prevent at scale for
decades, right? Uh take buffer
overflows, right, number two on that
list. Um and by the way, these are the
same vulnerabilities that models like
Mythos are finding in software. Um and
buffer overflows were first documented
um about um I believe 30-plus years ago,
right? Um so we've had uh documented
instances of how to find and exploit
these vulnerabilities, and we also now
have languages that are memory safe,
right? Languages like Rust, Go, pretty
much any language um that that's not C
or C++
um is built in a way such that it's
impossible to introduce memory safety
vulnerabilities, right? They have
guarantees that prevent those from being
introduced.
So we have techniques by which we can
prevent them and yet they continue
getting introduced over and over again,
right? So so let's look at memory safety
for instance.
There's you know the statistics range
but approximately 60 to 70% of
vulnerabilities in products written in
memory unsafe languages
can be completely prevented using memory
safe languages, right?
And this is you know based on CV data
out there and not only that right we've
seen a lot of companies Google,
Microsoft, Amazon even you know open
source software
the Linux kernel is being rewritten in
parts in rust. We've seen real evidence
that by shifting to memory safe
languages you can reduce overall
vulnerabilities, right? On the right
here is a chart from Google showing the
rate of memory safety vulnerabilities
over time in the Android operating
system. What's interesting right is that
this isn't even you know they're they're
not even necessarily rewriting code in a
memory safe language. They're just
writing new code in a memory safe
language and even then right the percent
of memory safety vulnerabilities has
dropped quite dramatically from
you know about 75% in 2019 to maybe 30%
in 2022.
So to me that's personally quite
exciting, right? Because it means that's
not a given that we're going to continue
having these basic vulnerabilities over
and over again, right? And in part of
the you know high-level policy
conversation I think as a result has to
be not just how can we deploy these
frontier models to find one-off
vulnerabilities in software that is
something that we should be doing but at
the same time, right, I don't want to
miss out on opportunities to make our
software fundamentally more secure.
Right, we could pour millions of dollars
into essentially playing whack-a-mole
with vulnerabilities and patching them
one-off in some of the open-source
libraries that we all rely on, or we
could do a one-time rewrite, for
instance, to move some of these critical
libraries
into a language like Rust, right? And
then that will pay dividends for years
to come.
So this is really at the core of how I'm
thinking about this, right? Is what are
some of the fundamental changes that
companies, that open-source developers
can be making that can reduce
exploitation both by models today,
right, and models to come. Cuz the
advantage, right, of doing a rewrite,
for instance, is that if you have some
of these fundamental guarantees, then
even if the models get smarter, right,
Rust has programmatic guarantees such
that we know that memory-safe D
vulnerabilities in no circumstances
won't be possible to be introduced or
discovered.
Right, and all of this comes in the
context, too, of the fact that AI is
increasingly capable at, of course, both
writing code and then introducing
vulnerabilities.
You might have seen a couple months ago
one example where Opus 46, right, by all
accounts a very smart model, introduced
a vulnerability in a smart contract that
led to a couple million dollars being
stolen, right? So so while the models
are very smart and capable, often times
security is very contextual. And the
model just might not have the context in
order to know that it's introducing a
vulnerability, right? And this is
reflected in academic benchmarks.
One, for instance, here, Backsbench, you
can find that backsbench.com by
researchers at ETH Zurich, UC Berkeley,
uh finds that even the best models
introduce vulnerabilities about 20 to
40% of the time when writing code.
Right? Um and this shouldn't necessarily
come as a surprise. Um for one, right?
Models are trained on all of the world's
existing code, and humans haven't been
great at not introducing vulnerabilities
in code in the past. But two, right?
Increasingly, and this kind of lines up
with some of what we're seeing among our
customers, is that the vulnerabilities
being introduced are often and less so
the basic one-liner vulnerabilities, and
more so contextual issues. Right? Things
like authorization bugs that require an
in-depth understanding of a company's
business logic. Um and that's something,
right? Even if the model's very smart,
it's not being trained on your company's
proprietary information or how your own
um kind of, you know, threat model
works.
Um and that is why, you know, I believe
we're still seeing quite a high rate of
vulnerability introduction um even by
um, you know, by by all accounts very
intelligent models.
Um so so let's now think about, okay,
given that the vast majority of software
development is being done with AI, how
can we make sure that AI is capable of
writing secure-by-design software?
Right? And part of this is a shift we're
seeing in the level of autonomy um that
AI is um now given when it comes to
software development tasks. Right? We're
kind of moving up this ladder that
started with auto-complete to you know,
agents within Cursor, Claude Code that
can synchronously produce code, to now
increasingly these autonomous agents
that can work for an hour, hours at a
time, and produce quite large code
changes. Of course, the next step then
becomes agents that are reviewing code.
Um
and we we at Quarter believe that, you
know, within the next 6 to 12 months,
the majority of code that is being
shipped will be reviewed uh not by human
but by AI. Um I think that's just a kind
of natural consequence of the rate at
which companies need to move, given that
code review is not is now the bottleneck
and I don't think we're going to accept
that for very long.
Um so really, right, our perspective at
Corridor is around preventing
vulnerabilities before the pull request,
um as well as giving visibility into how
AI coding tools are being used. Um and I
think that's really essential, right, is
that security cannot be the blocker when
it comes to companies accelerating their
development, right? Um acceleration is
always going to win out. Um so when we
talk to security teams, the conversation
is less around should you allow your,
you know, development teams access to
coding agents? The answer is obviously
yes, right? It's more around how can you
do that with guardrails in place, right?
Because what we're seeing is that
without guardrails, yes, the coding
agents can introduce vulnerabilities,
um and in order to get to a point where,
you know, development can be more
autonomous, that code can start to be
reviewed um by AI and merged in without
as much human oversight, we really need
to have tooling in place that allows
security teams to have that assurance,
um and to to give the blessing to their
their engineering team to accelerate. Um
I I want to close with some of the
policy perspective, right? And um this
is in part tied to the recent export
controls on Mythos and Fable models,
right? As part of a letter uh led by
Mikayla Gyalcsamis, um where we urged
the White House to lift the export
controls on these models. And the
perspective there is that the benefit to
defenders far outweighs the risk, right?
These are very powerful and let's face
it, right, dual-use models that can both
be used to secure systems and also um to
exploit them. Uh to Anthropic's credit,
they have done a lot of work with the
Fable release, right, to have some
safeguards in place such that um they're
more skewed towards defenders than than
adversaries. Um but this is also coming
in the face of, right, increasingly
powerful open-weight models. Um you've
probably seen, you know, documented um
distillation attacks um where
open-weight model providers can train on
the output of um closed-weight models
and that um as a result is quickly
shrinking the, you know, timeline
between when a frontier closed-weight
model comes out and when open-weight
models catch up to that. Um so whether
we like it or not, right, adversaries
already have access to incredibly
powerful models um and they're already
using them today to exploit systems,
right? So to me it becomes more question
of how can we rapidly um get the kind of
capabilities in the hands of defenders
and I think that requires having these
models be more widely available.
Um one cool thing I had the opportunity
of doing a couple weeks ago was
testifying to uh the US Congress um on
the, you know, risks of both uh frontier
models as well as AI coding. Um my
recommendations had a couple elements,
right? One was to prevent
vulnerabilities in new code going
forward. I think this is something that
both every company as well as the US
government should be focusing on and
making sure that as development
accelerates, right, security isn't being
left behind there. Um second is to
harden the open-source foundation. Um
this is incredibly important, right,
especially since open-source software is
going to be the kind of proving ground
for a lot of adversaries, right, who
want to test out these models and
exploit vulnerabilities they find
due to, right, the exact nature that's
open-source. So, so you can just go and
run a very smart model on them and in
all likelihood find many novel
vulnerabilities.
Um so, so I think both the US
government, but then private companies
as well have a responsibility to help
shore this up. And like I mentioned,
right, it's not just about one-off, um
you know, vulnerability discoveries or
patches. It really has to be more
systemic and start to get into um
rewrites that can fundamentally reduce
the risk of vulnerabilities that can be
found whether by models today or in the
future.
Um and then the last area of my
recommendations were to foster an
ecosystem of American weight made
open-weight models, right? I think in
order for us to stay competitive here,
it can't just be closed-weight models
alone, right? Um there's a number of
reasons here, you know, one of those is
that for many companies, while there's a
place for for closed-weight models, you
also might want to do things like
fine-tuning models. Um and that is only
possible with an open-weight model. Um
so, so I think it is really essential,
right, that
um we have frontier open-weight models
coming out of the United States. We
haven't seen as much of that to date, um
but I think that's a critical element of
American competitiveness
when it comes to AI.
Um so, so that those were my overall
recommendations, right? And of course,
all of this is in the context of these
increasingly powerful models. The
hearing was, I believe, a few days
before, you know,
um Mythos and Fable came out. Um and
then, of course, all of the um export
control um actions that were taken. Um
so, this is an incredibly rapidly
evolving space, but I think that's why
it's all the more important to go back
to the basics, right? What are the
fundamental controls that can protect
against um any vulnerabilities that can
be discovered by models today or in the
future? And I think that's where we
really ought to be spending our time
using these models
um to make our systems more resilient.
Um, so that's my talk. Um, happy to be
reached. My email's here and thanks
everyone for tuning in.